all right Danielle Danielle where you
from originally where'd you grow up um
Eureka
California and tell me about your family
growing up my family growing up um so I
lived with my grandma and my grandpa and
um then my cousin and my cousins two
cousins live with me and I was molested
by my cousin so I had to move out of my
grandma's house into my step A's house
and um who was mean and I hated how old
how old were you in the s um when that
happened I when I moved into her house I
think I was 10 and um she didn't have
kids or anything and I was the only kid
there so after four years I um ended up
she told me to mow the lawn and it she
said it wasn't good enough so I went
back in and I like pulled I grabbed her
hair and I slammed her head into the
dryer and they took me out because I
wanted to live with my mom that's who I
wanted to live with but she was on the
streets doing drugs and stuff so she
know she couldn't take care of me but
after that happened they let me live
with my mom they dropped me off and I
went like from being a girl scouts and
all that to like shooting
drugs just like that overnight cuz she
lived on the streets and she was doing
drugs so but at what age did drug use
start for you um let's see
15 yeah I was 15 what drug was that um
started out with
Crystal I used to like snort lines and
smoke it and um run around with all
these older men like you know I guess I
had daddy issues or whatever but um
and let's see I started doing heroin
when I was 17 did you go to high school
no I only went eth grade yeah I was by
high school I think I went to ninth
grade for two
weeks yeah and you you've been living on
the streets for most of this time
um yeah I mean give or take I yeah for
the most part since um when I got here
um I lived on skido for 3 years and then
after after that I was in a house for
like 10 years yeah but then I then I
moved back home and
um was on the streets there for a couple
like about a couple years and now I'm
not but yeah you using the entire time
um yeah what is what is your drug now
fetty fit no like it like a lot of
people mhm yeah
it's I there was like I I don't even
like it but there's no heroin anymore
like there's heroin's gone like in my
town there's like you can't find it yeah
I'm I'm suspicious when people tell me
they're still heroin addicts yeah I'm
like where in the hell are you get I
don't know anyone who's who's selling
heroin but they say they're heroin
addicts yeah it's it's
crazy so how do you make a living now
well so um I was a prostitute and um I
just recently met a guy and um he asked
me to marry him and he bought me a card
and um so now I'm living with him and
I'm doing door
Dash but I still on the side you know
turn tricks or whatever are you are you
in love with him or is it just um I do I
like him a lot I actually do like him a
lot yes I do I like him a lot it's not
just that he's taking care of me I
actually genuinely do like the guy
that's nice yeah it is nice because
usually it's like grit your teeth close
your eyes and have to and and then
divorce him in a few yeah right just
like you know but no I genuinely like
this guy so it's I feel really lucky
that's nice but he met you as as a trick
yeah he yeah he picked me up as a trick
Y and like we he he kept each time we
dated he kept U record and he's like
well this is the 25th time we've seen
each other and I we kissed and then
after that it was over so kissing is the
thing that yeah well working girls won't
do yeah no girls not prostitutes really
don't kiss that
much yeah funny so and do you have
children no children I don't have any
children I have two little
dogs and my brother
um the reason I came down to LA right
now was was cuz I my brother has been
missing for like about 8 months and so I
was like well he was in the hospital at
Lancaster I thought right so when I
called there they're like he's not here
anymore so that's why I drove down here
to try to find him but
um so I called the Morgan he was there
I'm sorry so I have to take him home now
this just happened yesterday oh
yesterday mhm and that was probably a
fentel overdose actually he had an
abscess from heroin on his arm and he
did not take care of it for like two
years and it was just literally like you
could it was just barely like it was
like hella small and all his inside of
his you know arm you could see it rotted
away so bad that um it made him septic
and then his kidney started failing and
he got on dialysis and um then it just
he just died I guess they don't really
tell me much
so that's why I'm here right now yeah
but tell me tell me about this lifestyle
is this something that you well okay so
like I back home like it's a lot
different than here you know um I was on
a supposed to be coming to go to sell
some weed with a guy and um we got to B
Arizona he bought an airplane and left
me there I didn't I I was strong on
heroin I was dope sick I didn't have any
money so some lady bought my jewelry for
me which wasn't really anything special
but just to help me I think most like
you know more than likely but um I got a
bus ticket and I um was going home I got
here and I was hella dope sick and
there's like a 5H hour lay over here and
I stayed here for 13 years I like got
stuck on skid Road you left for the no
yeah for the first three years I was on
skid Road smoking crack and doing heroin
and um you wouldn't recognize me I was
it was crazy it was really crazy but but
SK is way different now it's I don't
think I can do it now cuz the people are
a lot different how was it changed I
mean before like it was like the homies
were everybody was like you didn't have
to worry there's a lot of crazies I feel
like other states drop their crazies off
here now they do because it's just full
of crazies like it was not it was it was
fun back in the day it was actually fun
like you know you had people that you
know you trusted and it's like now
everybody smokes that um cryst spice or
whatever it's and they're like all crazy
just crazy yeah it's a lot different I I
would definitely couldn't do it now at
all but um my drug use is like um now
I'm doing fentanyl I smoke it I probably
smoke like about a gram a day and um
I've always prostituted for my drugs for
the most part you know have you ODed
I've never ODed never even on heroin
I've never ODed thank God no I've never
ODed but um I when I was like younger I
caught um a lot of STDs from
prostitution you know it made it so I
can't have children so that's like a you
weren't using a condom no it's you know
I don't care what any girls say a l a
lot of guys don't won't do it I mean
that's
just you know on skid Ro and you're a
girl with prostitute you take hardly
anything you know it's really sad like
how they you know girls get treated cuz
it's like guys will come here cuz they
know it's going to be cheap and the
girls just take barely anything you know
it's while I was here I got oh my God
this is the CRA this is the scariest
thing that's ever happened to me when I
was here this dude in this white van
picked me up this older white guy with
like a long hair and he got me in the
van and he pulled out a knife and he
said I'm not done with you and I was
like okay so he then he like handcuffed
me behind my back and he raped me for
like two hours he made me he put inema
water in my ass and he made me [__] in a
bowl and eat it and it was
like I thought he started strangling me
at the end and I was like begging him
not to you know please don't kill me I
was wait did he did or you did no he I
was tell he's like tell me he was going
to kill me I was like please don't kill
me you know and um who who had to eat
the uh I had to eat this [__] Jesus yeah
I had to eat this [__] well he so he he
started like he's like laughing he's
like haha I guess I won't and he ended
up making he wanted to drop me off where
he picked me up which was on the next
block down the street actually from
where we are right now and um I got out
of the car and I had [__] all over me
and it was it was just like but I and I
had a warrant so I was afraid to go to
the cops and that so I never got you
know to get that man in trouble or
anything like that's [__] up you know
and who knows what happened to him but
um and I still had to turn around and go
do another date because I didn't he
didn't pay me you know after all that so
your drug use takes you to [__] some
gnarly places or Minds it anyways you
know like I just had to wipe the [__]
off me and get back in the next car you
know what I mean it was pretty [__] up
yeah the things that people will do for
their absolutely it's for their drugs is
amazing it is really amazing but I've
also met some really cool people I can't
you I mean you're marrying one of
them right you know absolutely and the
guy that that took care of me while I
was living in La he's he's still one of
my best friends too you know he's saved
my life big
time definitely and he started out as a
trick too so what's your biggest
regret my biggest regret is
not staying at my real father at my real
father's um with their family I ran away
to be with some dude that just got out
prison and I didn't you know they were
they took me in for a couple years and I
took off and I didn't stay with them and
I that's probably my biggest regret and
I miss my grandma's funeral so I regret
that too do you think you have a
self-destructive
streak oh I'm yeah I'm sure I do like
anytime I start to get successful at
anything it's like
I always make sure I do something to
[__] it up you know well that's what it
seems like anyways you
know and emotionally what do you go
through living that life emotionally I
just turn off really I mean which is
[__] up for everybody else that wants
to get close to me because it's just a
lot easier when you're jumping in out of
cars all night and everything you know
what I mean and you're getting high and
it's like you if you feel all that [__]
that's a going to be overwhelming so I'm
really good at just like sh [__]
off what would you say is your biggest
fear my biggest fear wow my biggest
fear man what is my biggest fear
dying not a fental overdose no I'm not
I'm not I don't I not ever doesn't scare
me for some reason I'm not afraid of it
I don't ever feel like I'm going to OD
on it I don't know why but I just I just
don't it's just cuz my whole life I've
never done it OD yet so but I am afraid
to die
though and and then I'm just really sad
right now because like my brother was
alone that whole time he didn't have
anybody and he had to die alone you know
that's kind of messing with me right did
you guys communicate I talked to him and
he told me to send him a bus ticket and
when I called back he was already
gone oh but was your relationship like
with your
family um so with my family um my real
dad shot himself in the head when I was
like a month old and my mom was on the
streets doing drugs so she didn't really
she never wanted to be a mom really so
and then um my cousins well my one
cousin molested me so you know um I have
an aunt who I don't talk to don't really
it's always just pretty much been the
street as my family I don't really have
you know I have a stepfather who I can't
stand do do you see the connection
between the chaotic childhood you had
and where you're at today oh absolutely
absolutely yeah it' be interesting to do
an experiment with somebody who if you
had a twin sister who grew up in a oh
great so like if I would have stayed
with my Aunt Carrie and never left to go
to my mom my life would be totally
different I'm sure of it I would have
went to school and I would have went to
to college and I would have gotten a job
I would have children today and I would
totally know that my life would be one I
mean it would just totally be the
opposite
if I would have stayed there but I
wasn't happy there I was miserable there
so you
know Danielle what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life the lesson I've learned wow
let me think um the lesson I've learned
in my life let's
see man that's a hard one um [__] what
lessons have I learned in my
life
um not to just don't quit you know when
[__] gets like where I've been at the
lowest of the lowest of the lowest don't
give up you know you know maybe not
tomorrow it's going to be different you
know what I mean do you still have hope
of getting clean one day um yeah
absolutely like right now like when I
get back home I'm supposed to be going
to get on the methanone program and you
know because this is probably my one
chance you know to have a a little bit
of normality in my life you know so you
know have a home and and a husband and
cuz I've never been marri or anything
like that I can't have children but
that's okay I have the dogs
so I think just that if I just keep on
doing what I'm doing right now and and
then I just make the next right choice
then I'll be all right I
think all right Danielle thank you so
much for sharing your story I wish you
all the luck in the world thank you
thank
you
that